let's revisit the line integral f dot n
d s right over here because i want to
make sure we have the proper conception
i was a little loosey-goosey with it in
the last video and in this video i want
to get a little bit more exacting and
actually use units so that we really
understand what's going on here so i've
drawn our path c and we're traversing it
in the positive counterclockwise
direction and then i've taken a few
sample points for f at any point in the
x y plane it associates a two
dimensional vector maybe at that point
the two-dimensional vector looks like
that maybe at that point the
two-dimensional vector looks like that
and then n is of course the normal the
unit normal vector at any point at any
point on our curve the outward i should
say the outward pointing unit vector at
any point on our curve now in the last
video i talked about f as being some
type of a velocity function that at any
point gives you the velocity of the
particles there and that wasn't exactly
right in order to really understand
what's happening here in order to really
conceptualize this is kind of flux
through the boundary the rate of mass
exiting exiting this boundary here we
actually have to introduce a density
aspect to f so right over here i've
rewritten f and i've rewritten it as a
product of a scalar function and a
vector function so the scalar part right
over here rho of x y rho is the greek
letter is a greek letter often used to
represent density of some kind in this
case it's mass density
so at any given xy point
it kind of this tells us what the mass
density is mass density will be in some
mass we're in a two-dimensional world so
it's mass per area and if we want to
pick particular units for our example
once again this isn't the only way that
this can be conceived of there's other
applications but this is the easiest way
for my brain to process it we can
imagine this is kilogram per
kilogram per square
meter and this right over here is a
velocity vector it tells us what is the
velocity of the particles of that point
so this is kind of saying how many how
much particles do you have and kind of a
point how dense are they and then this
is how how fast are they going and in
what direction
and this whole thing is a vector
it's a velocity vector but the
components right over here m of x y m of
x y is just a number and you multiply
that times a vector so m of x y right
over here
is going to be a scalar function when
you multiply it times i becomes a vector
that's going to give you a speed
and then n of x y is also going to give
you a speed and then it tells you a
speed in the j direction so it becomes a
vector a speed in the i direction
becomes a vector as well but these
speeds
the units of speed so let me write this
over here the speeds
the unit of speed so now we're talking
about in particular m of x y and n of x
y that would be in units of distance
distance per time and so maybe for this
example we'll say the units are meters
per second so let's think about what the
units will be for this function if we
distribute the row
if we distribute the row because really
in any given xy it really is just a
number so if we do that we're going to
get f is going i'm not i'm not going to
keep writing f of x y we'll just
understand that f rho m and n are
functions of x y
f is going to be equal to
rho
times m
rho times m
times the unit vector i
plus
rho
plus rho times n
n times the unit vector j now what are
the units here
what's rho times m what units are going
to get are we going to get there and
we're going to get the same units when
we do rho times n
well we're going to have if we pick
these particular units we're going to
have kilograms
kilograms per meter squared times meters
per second
times meters per second so a little bit
of dimensional analysis here one this
meter in the numerator will cancel out
with one of the meters in the
denominator
and we are left with something kind of
strange kilograms per
kilograms per meter second which is
essentially what the the
if you view this this vector has a
magnitude in some direction the
magnitude component is going to have is
going to have these units right over
here and then we're going to take this
and we're dotting it with n n just only
gives us a direction it is a unitless
vector it is only specifying a direction
at any point in the curve and so when i
take a dot product with this it's going
to give us essentially what is the
magnitude what is the magnitude of f
going in the direction going in the
direction of n
so this right over here
when you take the dot let's say that
it's essentially the magnitude a part of
the magnitude of f going in n's
direction and so it's going to have the
same exact units as f so the units of
this part
you're going to have kilograms per meter
second and then we're going to let me
make this very clear so let's say we're
focusing on this point right over here f
looks like that it's magnitude the
length of that vector is killer is going
to be in kilograms per meter second then
we have a normal vector right over there
and when you take the dot product you're
essentially saying what's the magnitude
that's going in the normal direction
so essentially what's the magnitude
what's the magnitude of that vector
right over there it's going to be in
kilograms per meter second and then
we're multiplying it times ds we're
multiplying it times this
infinitesimally small chunk of or a
little segment of the curve we're going
to multiply that times ds well what are
the units for ds it's going to be unit
of length we'll just go with meters so
this right over is going to be meters so
you're going to have this whole integral
you're going to have kilogram per meter
second times meters so if you have
kilograms per meter
second and you were to multiply that
times meters you were to multiply that
times meters what do you get well this
meter is going to cancel with that
meters and then you get something that
kind of starts to make sense you have
kilogram
per second and so this hopefully makes
it clear what's going on here
this is telling us how much mass is
crossing that little ds that little
section of the curve per second and if
you were to add up and that's what
integrals are all about adding up an
infinite number of these into
infinitesimally small dss's if you were
add all of that up you're going to get
the value of this entire integral is
going to be in kilograms in kilograms
per second and it's essentially going to
say how much mass is exiting this curve
at any given point or at any given time
so this is
mass so this whole integral so the whole
integral
the whole integral we rewrite it of f
dot n
d s
tells us the mass
mass exiting
exiting
the curve
the curve
per
per second and this should also be
consistent in the last video we saw that
this is equivalent to and this is where
we kind of view it as a two-dimensional
divergence theorem in the last video we
saw that this is equivalent to the
double integral over the area of the
divergence of f which is essentially
just well i could write two ways the
divergence of f and this right over here
that's just the partial
the partial of
let me write it down here so i have some
space the partial of the i component
with respect to x let me write it over
here i don't want to do this too fast
and loose
so this right over here is going to be
the partial
of
rho m
let me write it like this rho m
with respect to x
plus the partial of the y component
rho n
with respect with respect to y
times each little chunk of area times
each little
times each little chunk of area
well what are the units what are the
units of this going to be right over
here we know what rho m is rho m gives
us kilogram per meter second but if we
take essentially the derivative with
respect to meters again the units here
are going to give the units for either
of these
the units for either of these characters
are going to be
kilograms
per meter
second per second because we're taking
the derivative with respect sorry per
meter we're taking the derivative with
respect to another unit of distance so
you're going to take per meter so you're
going to have another meter right here
in the denominator that's going to be
the units here and then you're
multiplying it times an area you're
multiplying it times you're multiplying
it times an area so that would be meter
squared that's right this right over
here is square meters they cancel it out
and once again this whole part right
over here that you're summing up gives
us kilograms
kilograms per second so you're having a
bunch of kilograms per second it and
you're just adding them up throughout
throughout the entire
the throughout this entire area right
over here so hopefully this makes a
little bit more sense about kind of how
to conceptualize this vector function f
if it confuses you
try your best to ignore it i guess but
uh
for me at least this this helped me out
conceptual having a stronger conception
of what vector f could kind of represent